Ursula has a really clean line and
everything that she ever wrote and I
admire this because one of the things
that takes his focus on what is your
story really about so if you're ready in
a novel there's two years that are
passing you're reading about it doing
research for it you learn lots of
stories and what happens to me is
anything well all these stories are so
great I have to put them all in and I go
into a fit an obsessive fit I'm thinking
that's so interesting I can't possibly
not include it and so is this and so is
that
and so my novel is kind of like they
began to bulge as I want to tell every
great story that I ever occurs to me
during the two years of reading the
novel it's you know it's something I
can't control
Ursula she would know what the story
needed to tell you in order to make the
maximum effect for however long it was
so her novels aren't very long and
they're in in proportion to how long
they are because she made them as long
as they needed to be let me I want to
read a sentence to you yeah this is a
little section on it just to give you a
sense of it it is always the year one
here only the dating of every past and
future year changes each New Year's Day
as one counts backwards or forwards from
the unitary now so it was spring of the
year one and Erin rang capital city of
car Hyde and I was in peril of my life
and did not know it I was in a parade
I walked just behind the Gaza wars and
just before the king
it was raining rain clouds over dark
towers rain falling in deep streets a
dark storm beaten city of stone through
which one vein of gold winds slowly that
image you just see it and I think her
sentences this comes from the very first
pages of the left-handed darkness it
struck me at the time and I've never
forgotten it I could find it very
quickly when I was putting this talk
together her sentences are like that
line of gold
run through the thing and there a kind
of living wire of thought that you can
follow when you read it and that I think
is really part of her talent as a writer
and then of course the content she's
strange but she's not too strange to
understand and she again keeps it a
focus on the main point so most of her
stories have one strange thing and
everything else is more familiar to you
so you can accept it
she's also that's what makes her
available to so many readers almost any
reader who enjoys any kind of fiction
can actually understand the Guin you
don't have to be a specialist in science
fiction or know the history of science
fiction she can indeed be her entry jug
for that reason and she there's also a
playfulness to her a playfulness and a
sense of humor even in her and heaviest
stories and maybe it's not true say of
Tejano but for every one of the River
novels no matter how much she is
basically a serious writer there's a
playfulness in the prose and in them and
in the talk between the characters which
is and I wanted this picture up here to
kind of convey that that's a quality in
her writing right there
so there's something that you can only
put together as a kind of a gestalt that
has to do with um intelligence and
creativity a kind of a vision a warmth
the warmth is important and I'm gonna
come back to that and it adds up to
something that we often call wisdom or
greatness I'd like I prefer the word
greatness because who knows what wisdom
is in this world but the the great
artists have some quality that actually
as you might be able to tell from what
I'm saying now you can't quite put your
finger on it but you know it's there
when you've read enough of that writer
it doesn't mean that they are the finest
stylists or the most poetical in fact
that is often the surfer that's doing
too many turns it's more has to do with
the content of what she's saying and it
doesn't have to do with being deadly
serious you don't have to be I don't
want to even name the writers who try to
see that they're important by their
deadly seriousness that isn't what she
would do
[Music]